[Music]
I'm just curious this is your job to
cover the debate to watch the debate
we're didn't you where do you watch the
debate you go to a special room and
watch it is there a special place you
guys watch it sometimes I have a special
place yeah I've been with these focus
groups of supposedly undecided voters
most of them are right and I watch with
them and they grade the debate and then
last night I was coming to see you so I
watched the debate in the air Oh
what airline were you on I was on
JetBlue so oh so JetBlue so you watched
the debate happening with a planeload of
people yeah it was it was a full plane
load of people and they how many of them
were watching the debate be honest maybe
about 60% really okay but you know that
many undecided voters so maybe that was
it but I sort of had a tough spot you
know I I had had a window seat right and
I was excited about that my producer
will though he said he pulled this whole
I'm really tall thing can you sit in the
middle
sure so I did uh-huh and you know the
etiquette on the plane you know that the
person in the middle should get to have
the arm rests yeah no both of them took
the arm rests okay that's why I watch
the debate there you watch the debate
you have the headphones on and
everything else and what was your sense
as you talk to people in the plane what
they thought yeah I talked to the woman
next to me she actually had the debate
on but she wasn't she just didn't have
the audio on so as she was watching it
at the end she said most exciting way to
watch it yeah she said who do you think
won the debate and I said oh well you
know they both tried to do what they
needed to do which because why won't you
answer my question you were taking notes
you reporter I said yeah I'm a reporter
oh is that why you won't say who won the
debate who do you work for I said CNN
she goes oh yeah in the can for Obama
she was just not having it she wasn't
having it but you know she took the
armrest all right you you brought it up
the undecided voters you know when you
watch when you watch that that's CNN
graphic I don't know how people feel
about it I find it very distracting the
men and the women the two lines going up
and down do you reacting to what the
candidates are saying does it really
tell us anything those two lines do you
guys pay attention to those lines or is
that just some eye candy to make it look
more fun on television well a little bit
of its eye candy I have to say when I
watched it I can see what you're saying
but but you know what the focus groups
that I did right afterwards when they
voted you know who do they think won and
on the issues they actually ended up
being with the national polls showed a
few days later so I don't know on the
second by second thing maybe that's a
little bit much but they were accurate
in their read of it here's what I've
noticed they tend to go up when the
candidate starts to speak and then when
the candidate stops they sloped down
then when they speak again it goes up
and all we're doing is measuring
people's ability to tell when someone's
talking that's what I see yeah that's
sort of it I mean the rule is when the
moderator speaks you're supposed to say
you could supposed to go to neutral
right so maybe that's what you saw but
yeah I mean it's so no I'm pretty sure
I've cracked this thing there are two
weeks left two weeks to go how many more
polls do we need and do you think we're
pulling too much do you think it's time
to just do turn I mean like it seems
like there's there's 35 different
companies that take polls and they they
they release their polls like 15 times a
day and so I don't know about the rest
of you I just get so inundated I don't
know what's happening there really 35
company I'm making this up because there
might be no there might be I mean I'm
making it all up it's none of its true
well do we need that many polls no but
but in my business to keep people like
me employed yes okay so we need
something so this is all about you this
is good for you okay all right then I
want more I want more balls just for you